What is up, how's it going, Poodiepie here. We're playing part two of South Park The Fractured But Whole. It's so fun so far
I'm loving it and
Thank you guys so much for all the love the support in the first video
Yes, we did it. We just picked our superhero. He looks, look at him. He's got that uuhhhh oh my god
Everyone say I look at like him, Guy or whatever
That flaming shit brother. Hell Yeah! We picked the right character. That's for shizzle
We picked the right character look at it goddamn, beautiful
Coonstagram, okay guys let me know if I..I should not do the Cartman voice.
If any time scrambles out of there okay fine
You're.. the mayor's aides
Say, she's too busy to worry about the cat, what? I can't read. I'm illiterate. Hey. She's took away the lava
Hold L2 to find people to take selfies with for Coonstagram
You can take selfies with people that have a camera icon above their heads okay to regress a selfie approach someone and press R1 okay?
Let's get out of the picture here, what mood do we want? I was something I zoom in on her tits or something
There it is we got a new follower
Sure
We're an influencer
Coonstagram
Miss Furnicle is now a follower only people who pose with yourself will follow you it's basically
follow follow for follow press
To see who you are following, okay? We're following her as well, yeah
We're one of these lame celebrities that just follow everyone to get followers
All right we need more respect we need more street cred. I get it. Let's go this way you want to take a selfie
No, no, let's go and take a selfie with Butters dad. That's not weird right?  hey, buddy
oh
Wow we can add a filter
why is this a thing?!
I guess we got to take more selfies
Level up our influence
This is just like real life. I really they really breached the gap finally. It's that a sword? Can I... no.
Okay, he's gonna want to take a selfie then
Shut your... why does no one want to take a selfie with me? it's just like real life damn it
Oh the Chinpokomon, I love that episode, classic. All right you then
That doesn't look weird at all
Ah
Bless, did I not do it. I don't understand R1. Help me with this thing. It's stuck. Okay. We got to help him first
stuck
There you go you just punch it. So dumb
Yeah, I'm the real deal, let's take a selfie.
This is so lame
Whatever
It's so cute- Kawaii Cartman
Ok, nice
now
Thank you. God damn
Yeah when you have two followers, that's that's when you know you really hit those
We're friends now. I guess
Let's take this stupid selfies
Yes!
YES!!
Shut up
Let's check the map Google Maps
Can't seem to forget it there. We go alright. L1 are available mission
Okay, talk to super Craig. Okay. Just like that
And then we have the mini-map, okay cool
we literally just have to walk to the left, so let's do that ♪Beebee di bop dap bee dub pa pyuru♪
Ah, the classic
The nostalgia
Are we gonna fight?
There might be some boobs in Wonder ...
Yeah, no I did it. I literally just did it
Stop this at once
Yeah, that's how it's done! begin, he's grossed out, okay
Alright let's kick this guy's ass
Wow, you are so brave. Let's go. Let's go. I may have missed one of them
Shit
Come on. Oh
not a wet...
Press X turning attack, okay
He's both grossed out and burning this should be a cake in the park walk in the cake
Please don't die new kid. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Uuuhhhhhh.....
That one doesn't do that much. I don't know why I used this one, but whatever
Got'em
I think we can just literally punch him
We won we did it everyone and we got a clump of cat hair
that's truly a reward worthy of a superhero of our status
I really liked scorch I'm glad we picked this one
Keep it up Ethan proud of you Wow okay now give me a min...
Ok, shut up... shut up
Let's take a stupid selfie you really want a selfie with me not really, but I need Kunz to grandfather mercy
Why don't you defeat that sixth grader with so cool just stop talking stop talking. Thank you. Hi guys. What's up?
Don't mind me just looting your house
Help Jimmy finish up his big project in sure now take yourself. Oh, this is so lame fine fine
Jimmy are you up here? Can you use that oh?
He has a handicap toilet
All right, we found some good shit should we take a shit it's been a while. I know this is a difficult one
There it is
Oh
It's tricky ah
Yeah, okay
Jeremiah oh
God it's tricky is tricky ah
no, uh
No little release
That was a hard one
Man I'm loving this game so far he completely uneventful mm-hmm
So dope
I just want to explore everything that doesn't really happen for me in games usually people get pissed off at me
It's definitely something new oh
Yeah, I even forgot our quest was to find super crane there we go oh
My controller got stuck
We have crafting can we punch this as what?
No those explosive might be useful later, but for now let's check out
super Krang
I'm sorry, but I cannot assist anyone with their problems right now super Kraig can't fight his guinea pig
Oh the coud that I'm not playing until I find stripe. He's not just adorable guinea pig he belongs to B and my ex-boyfriend
That's right. Super craig is gay. I'll bet stripe is down to the basement again
We should start at the basement. That's the last place I saw
Craig and tweek
Wasn't it I?
Think it may be he smelled the dog food
All rights in the basement. Let's find him well dad by the stairs that keep him from escaping you do the rest butthole be careful
Snap and pops on line oh
Those might be handy, you're welcome. You're welcome
Thank you. I can we pass oh
Well luckily oh
I second okay. Oh my god. I'm gonna kill him aren't I oh?
Thank god he's the life come on
Oh my god, oh
Oh no oh no oh
I'll figure out his alive
I'm just glad he's alive
How oh, I dragged it right Wow
Can you stop?
I
Killed it now didn't aim
What do I eat for these farts man oh I
Used that me guinea pig
It was she I had to one was called cheese
And the other one was named after me if it was called feed left field is like a
Nickname for Felix in Sweden it's so dumb alright. Let's take a shopping
On Coons to Graham
Okay I
Don't know why I'm doing this
But we did it got a level up that influence of dog
New kid yeah, what up?
Hey there. Oh, you want a Craig's friends you're looking for Craig. No
Me. Let's just say I'm an art collector now. What is happening flea modern an extremely confusing Asian art for what?
Crazy right
But this stuff is worth a fortune to the right buyer if in your adventures you find any of these bring them to me
It is so messed up
Come back with any new pieces you find rain kids better appreciate this goddamn thing. Oh wow
Okay, alright, they went there. Huh that's cool. So you can actually find more of the art
Craig and tweek, I ship them so hard they were on point with that episode. I was like damn. That's fuckin awesome
Alright no drone zone. Can you use drones later then?
Okay, so we have the snaps now so maybe we can try it out like oh
Wow we did a baddy I
feel like oh
Should we stay or oh?
I see I see I see there you go a
Recipe oh cool so we can get a new outfit. That's awesome
Alright don't
How you doing there buddy, oh here you don't look like one of Henrietta's chums
Hey, the game looks so good. It really feels like you're playing interesting get up. You one of those free range kids, okay, buddy
It really feels like you're playing some
Intense crunch did you guys ever play that old the softball game on Nintendo 64. That was so fun
All those turkeys that you had to kill in that game my god
We forgot here as well, maybe we should try it just for fun
Okay, then I'm out of ideas. Let's check our
customs okay power source Anil
Great
Okay, what do we got crap thing?
Okay, so you can craft anyway?
so came a craft ik
We need crafter rank seven okay. We can craft some
Revived serum that seems pretty good. Let's do that
Maybe that will help us level up a bit as well, okay, we need to find more stuff
Because I want to make that outfit that looks coal
Consumables we don't have to check let's I want to check like our missions
Meet Kyle at his house pin it and let's go oh
My god
You dad
It's Lego oh my
Cute ants what fam em hey you want to take a selfie girl, hey, what up
What in the world okay? Can we our okay? Let's not do that it is actual lava. How about that?
DLC
Alright, let's just ignore these guys for now probably you have to fight them to keep going
Later in the area
This is so dope
Sorry by hitting that by accident is the most annoying shit
Hey kid, you know anything about this somebody's keying my wife's car. It's happening every night
I thought it was just one of you damn kids, but wolf here come here
Take a look at this get on Randy one of my favorite characters matching the car is also leaving notes. I'm just scared
It's jilted lover or something
You won't forget me that easy. I thought we had something
I'll tell the world about you bitch listen. I'm sick of having to puff this shit out if you can catch
Whoever's keying my wife's car tonight. I'll follow you on Instagram. Okay. You want me as a phone. I'm a pretty big deal instead
This is a side quest
I'm happy to do it
Cuz I mean he's a pretty big deal, right
Plus we are playing on 'hardest difficulty
Yeah, let's go in here should we
All right there, yes, how are you? It's a me?
Sorry kid but my problem is too big for a rookie a few days ago
There was an anomaly in the universe another version of me the human kite from an alternate dimension showed up here
And is destroying everything right now. It's upstairs in my room. I don't think anything can stop it
Go to cow's room okay?
You look so weird
Human kite from another universe is behind this door
I can't fight it for obvious reasons you know alternative universe paradox shit, so you are going to have to take him out
Yeah, I want to fight dude so that he wants to return back to his universe on the 8th. Go who is this gonna be
Who is it?
The human kites him from a universe
He's the one running around giving to him a kite a bad name
He was sent here to destroy me and weaken my house no
No, I came to spend two weeks with my cousin and wanted to play superhero
I remember this episode but super here
Do you want to be and I said I want to be human kite, but he said you can't be human kite
I'm you mean kite, and I said well
Why can't we be human kites together so I went to aunt Sheila and I said I want to be human
I was the guest
He needs to die this man. You mean me
I'm sorry me from another universe, but it is time for you to learn that playing superheroes is too painful
New kid you must now destroy my alter-ego
100%
If you really want this how you do it well alright anything to make me and my cousin more like
They called me a weakling you called me a weakly
Yes, oh, I'm afraid that's impossible I didn't bring my pigs
Alright, let's just destroy him
We can beat him if we join Boise's yeah, I really want to my parallel universe will say I can't I
Keep missing it I need to learn how to do it properly well you're literally on fire
I'm sxi, whatever
Alright time for another tech I guess we can just I
Want to do it, okay, I'll do it next
Okay
What can't pull shit like that
Oh my god
You're so annoying okay, I hit it too early, that's what I'm doing
No stop I hate you
Okay has protection indicated by the blue bar. Okay. Yeah fine, whatever
Preferably prescription-strength, but I should go beyond the screen okay, let's use another attack
So I think it should be
I don't want to cause any from any damage. I want you to burn
Okay, you don't burn watch me do it properly this time
And seem to get it oh
My god. Yes, I'm ready
Oh wow he's doing it he's beginning to believe yes
Yeah
Hey, we got the Hawkeye mass nice and we level up how about that I
Hope you did
Oh, you're leaving dude, that sucks yeah going back to that universe now human kite
I need some came to Phoenix for my ear because I got a scrape on it baby farted on
Dude, I don't know how to thank you from now on ecology. Whatever you need help
This is st. This is it guys selfie. Let's do it selfie time
Heck yeah nice
Okay, let's go down. That was awesome
Okay, so why do you get so quiet?
Now we can find yah we in South, LA
Hey remember that
All right, let's go back to the Coon lair which of course is right next to us
The cuny oh
It's in the basement my bed
So I have to enter the code again amazing my sorry mom
You pee mom
Sorry fuck you mom
So dumb
Being a superhero is a little harder than you thought huh. Yep, it's okay
No totally suck, but I can't help but feel sorry for you because your dad
This way I'm gonna teach you about artifacts you see most superheroes augment their abilities with specialized equipment
You'll find things like these out of its ham the trick is to equip them into your artifacts sluts go on get this
What in the world
Okay, every artifact has a specific place it can be slotted on your body. Uh-huh equip this one to boost your strength stats
Did it it might be a little uncomfortable at first your DNA is fusing with it
You'll find more other facts out there doing your superhero adventures we can even craft your own just remember
Great power comes great bat sir. I think you're ready to take on those sixth graders now. Oh hell yeah
But Lord is going let's do this. I'm ready
We could do there Randy quest as well. I just don't know how we doesn't need to find who did it
What we can also do it later. What is this? Oh?
Now we can fast travel
thanks to
Okay
Activate the Mainstreet fast okay nice
We should fart on them before we find him
Meredith let's do this. Oh, we can help Austin
Let's try mastermind, I don't think it'll be that difficult
So we can actually start with here we go oh
This might be difficult, they do a lot of events oh
Nice it's pretty big
Damn they do a lot of damage oh you did not just say that
Can you guys tank some damage?
Can you give burritos to other people I don't think so, I don't know what Cal can do okay, that's a long range
You can heal
Okay, let's do that, and then he can
Craig's blocking paralyzes him to deflect damage. Okay doesn't do any damage at all I
Don't know why that was let's eat this burrito as well
Why am I gross that was it a disgusting burrito
Okay, cool. Let's see what happens then nice oh
My god that is alive
We almost have our super though okay, oh no no no
Seriously
Oh, I see okay, we can only be here
I'm really trying hard here guys. There's only one guy in left. Okay, now. It's time to use it
Yes yes
Come on
It didn't do that much damage. Oh wow he does a lot image
Here we go there it is
I went over gear yeah
That's what's right? That's what's good done diddle mastermind
I
Probably won't do more mastermind. Just because I took way too long
Let's go
But before we go I have to end this episode here
I'll make it super long episode tomorrow if you guys keep showing your support with likes and
Comments and all that shit really appreciate you guys. I'm having so much fun. Thank you guys. I really mean it
See you tomorrow squad fam brofist